time catches up with everybody well
here's something I haven't done in a
little while time for a Big Finish
review I even though I've kind of taken
these off the dockets at least in terms
of them being a regular feature I have
had the joy of having some of my patreon
supporters commissioned some specific
reviews of stories they really wanted me
to do and this time that was the Eighth
Doctor time war set series one I think
there have been four of these to date at
time of recording I think so anyway this
is the first series of such and it does
deal with how the time war is starting
to impede and encroach on the eighth
doctor aka Paul McGann's life now if you
aren't especially familiar with the Big
Finish and extra material that is out
there of which I'm only really just
starting to skim the surface of myself
and you stick to the main show itself
you may only really know Paul McGann
either from the TV movie in 1996 or from
more likely the short night of the
doctor if you've never seen neither the
doctor seriously pause this go watch it
it's about eight minutes come on back
and you'll understand why it's great to
get anything more with Paul McGann now
since I can now safely assume everyone
has seen night of the doctor we
definitely get the implication there
that he really tried to not get involved
in the time war that would seem to be
his mission in so many ways like I am
NOT getting involved in this thing well
this series shows that his decision to
stay out of it mm-hmm that that's that's
not a choice that's easy to follow
through on because this thing was so big
and so all-encompassing that you
you couldn't get away from it so there
are four stories in this set as there
usually is in the box sets at least most
of the ones that I have encountered up
to this point so I'm gonna take these
one at a time I will avoid spoilers for
as long as I can I am gonna have to get
into spoilers talking about the last one
in particular because some of the stuff
that is especially interesting about
that one requires spoilers the other
ones I can I think keep it pretty
decently spoiler free of really only
talking about general premise so the
first part is the starship of Theseus
which is a very clever and interesting
piece the first thing is if you are at
all familiar which I am with the
philosophical thought exercise the Ship
of Theseus then you might kind of suss
out some of the tricks that this
particular episode has up its sleeve but
even if you see them coming they are
very well implemented as the time war
starts to encroach on this ship that the
doctor and is companion Sheena just kind
of turn up on and they're just it's a
it's a cruise ship like oh well this
will be fun but then things just start
to shift and alter and something is very
very wrong
about the way that this thing moves
about in space and how it gets from
point A to point B at a certain toll
that has to be paid so Magan is great in
all of these top two bond from the back
he is just terrific so I don't even
really need to reiterate that again and
we also in this meet the characters that
we're actually going to be sticking with
through the entirety of the run because
there are a number of characters coming
off of this adventure who will continue
to be with the doctor most notably the
character of bliss who effectively
serves as a new
I'm paying in by the time the things
wrapped up and there's also a couple
named Quarren and Roopa and there are a
few other characters as well but these
are the main ones that are gonna carry
over and so they all get introduced and
the ways in which they are each going to
be significant isn't immediately
apparent but it's interesting watching
that developed over the course of this
and this story is interesting because I
think one of the things that this boxset
does especially well is showing the ways
in which the time war is impacting
reality the way that it is causing
collateral damage and how some of the
weapons of the time war get used and the
fallout from the use of them and that
starts right off the bat with this and
it just that is kind of the through line
that continues through the entirety of
this thing that the way in which this
war gets waged it causes damage of a
completely different nature from
anything else you'd normally expect from
fallout of a war so we get that right
off the bat with starship of Theseus and
then it goes into echoes of war now
echoes of war is sort of a a little bit
of a trek through a dangerous wilderness
kind of story but there's a twist to it
because obviously since this is the time
war we are dealing with the Daleks in
various capacities in in each of these
stories now with echoes of war we have a
Dalek
that has been damaged in such a way that
it doesn't quite remember what it is and
what's going on and so because it has
capabilities that the doctor and the
other folks don't have and kind of need
they team up with it and it agrees to
help them because it doesn't fully
remember what it is and so they haven't
they're starting to trust it and it's
starting to have experiences that might
teach it to trust them but at the same
time they are all in fear that the
things gonna have a full memory recovery
remember what it is and what its goals
are and so that dynamic is interesting
and and the dalek not fully realizing
what it is and its place in the universe
effectively is a nice little sort of way
to play with basically another spin on
enemy mind you know it's fairly well I
mean that wasn't even the first story to
do it's just the first one that comes to
my head yeah you know the sort of sci-fi
people on opposite sides of a conflict
they got to work together to survive
it's not exactly a news story but it's
got a few little twists to it and again
we're continuing to see fallout from the
time war across this story so that moves
things along as well unfortunately in
this installment we also get introduced
to I think easily the weakest character
of the entire box set it's a character
who sticks around through the remaining
entries that characters a Time Lord
holding the rank of cardinal and her
name is a Lystra and okay when she first
shows up she's pretty effective for what
she is being utilized for which is a
very cold very goal and results-oriented
military strategist type she has no
particularly care for morality she cares
about results and she has a very cold
very even delivery that works for that
unfortunately as the character sticks
around and as events continue to unfold
around her she maintains that same way
of delivering lines and it just starts
to become inappropriate it's not quite
monotone but for the situation she
starts to find herself in the fact that
she is still as even-keeled as she is
and her line delivery starts to read is
just off and it doesn't quite feel like
the character is meant to be unflappable
because some of the lines like on paper
are exasperated or fearful or can
but that never enters into the vocal
delivery of those lines and it makes the
character a character who had been
functional if slightly generic at first
introduction kind of grading by the end
and it's a shame because she really is
the only flat-out weak part of this
entire box set but by the time it was
done I didn't care for her at all
[Music]
which is a bummer that's pretty rare
that I have something in these Big
Finish boxes that I can as definitively
point to his like that that did that
didn't work but I can with her so moving
on to the next story proper we have the
conscript now in this they the doctor
has basically been chucked into basic
training before the time war with
recruits much younger than him and he is
expected to fall in line and there are
things that I both like and dislike
about this one
although the things that I dislike about
it are things that whenever I talk about
this in relation to the Timelords
because it's come up before when I've
talked about them broadly speaking I
seem to be one of the only ones who
really get annoyed by this
so again speaking in general terms I
don't like when we find out things about
the Timelords and it runs too much of a
parallel to human beings and earth so
it's one of the things that bugs me
about heaven-sent
they have farms and just like
effectively an Amish community it's one
of the things that bugs me about the
deadly assassin they have TV news
broadcasts that are just you know like
our TV news
there's something very de mystifying in
a way that doesn't make them more
interesting whenever we get this very
overly familiar sense of who the Time
Lords are on what they do I'm not saying
that the Time Lords as entities need to
feel overly alien but it frustrates me
when their society feels so analogous to
our own it just feels like an easy
shortcut
it's just uninventive and I kind of find
it uninteresting so I do find it
frustrating that the general structure
of this the whole boot camp thing that
the doctor goes through is pretty much
you know what you see I mean I'm not
gonna say what you go through and you're
through boot camp I've never been
through boot camp I have no idea but
it's the kind of thing that you see
whenever boot camp gets depicted in
films television etc it very much falls
in line with the expectations there are
a couple of twists here and there as far
as getting again a little more insight
into the way the time war gets waged
both in terms of what the conscripts are
getting trained to do and some other
stuff that goes on later so that helps a
little bit and also the characters are
quite nice in this the doctor has a few
to deal with he has a commandant
effectively the drill sergeant that is
trying to not break him begin him to
fall in line and that's a very well
handled character especially considering
anything could have just been an
unredeemable jerk but he's obviously
trying very hard to do the best he can
to get young soldiers prepared for
something that is by definition
impossible to be prepared for and he
seems to know that there's nothing that
he can do they can truly properly
prepare them for what they are about to
go out and do but he's still gonna do
the best that he can it's a really
well-balanced performance and quite a
well-written character as well and there
are a couple of recruits who the doctor
kind of bonds with and they are both
well performed they have a nice sort of
performance chemistry and contrast with
each other so that works pretty well too
and then there's the last store where
everything kind of comes to a head and
we learn how all this is about the
tracking down of this one specific thing
that both the Daleks and the Time Lords
want and sort of the fallout from that
now I do have to get into spoilers on
this last one and I additionally we'll
be addressing some spoilers from the
earlier ones that I had to kind of skip
over so that's your spoiler warning and
here we go
so it turns out that what the Daleks and
the time woods are after after initially
we get kind of a hint that they're
tracking down the doctor duh of course
they're not it turns out that corn hat
is a Time Lord who used a chameleon
circuit and he has a pendant that once
he opens it up he will restore his time
or personality but what he is is he is a
Time Lord would be most extreme
capabilities I they don't call them
psychic but it's something along those
lines like he has a grasp and a
manipulation himself not even through
like a TARDIS or technology but a
manipulation of the time stream he just
has an inherent skill of that that is
off the charts and there's a couple of
things I like about this the first is
the this last one is called one life and
it's really great because far as nuts as
the concepts are getting by this point
it's grounded in the relationship
between corn and Rupa his wife and we
get these flashes of how they met and
you know their lives together their
marriage and all these things and then
we realized most of that is manufactured
and fake because Koren didn't just use a
chameleon circuit to create an identity
for himself he created an entire history
for both himself and Rupa that didn't
actually happen and it's it's quite sad
to first of all some of the glimpses we
get of that because it's very real and
very human and then to see that unravel
is quite sad and it's a really good idea
when you're dealing with concepts this
abstract to ground the story or at the
very least the emotional core of the
story in understandable human traits
which this does despite the fact that at
this point we are talking about a being
who is capable of rewriting the timeline
on a whim it still manages to ground it
in a relationship that we can understand
so that makes it work and I also kind of
really like the idea that neither the
time
nor the Daleks had any interest in the
doctor they were after somebody else and
part of what I like about that is it
goes against the thing that I've railed
against before which is the doctor being
like the most amazing special thing ever
in the history of the universe which I
don't care for so I rather like this
idea of he assumes because of his ego
that they're all after him but it's like
no we don't care about you this guy's
like oh so much better than you are I
like that and I also like seeing the
chameleon circuit used yet again so this
now marks the third time we've seen it
done makes you wonder how many other
Time Lords did it in some way to try and
escape the time war and also it's really
interesting you know cuz once he opens
it up and becomes his time law itself
again he oh he's not an uncaring person
but he's also he's much colder and he's
not the same person and it is
interesting that he was such a sweet
kind of timid guy very much like John
Smith was very much like Professor Jana
was it makes me wonder and I think I
might even headcanon this if the
chameleon arch when it is used to turn a
Time Lord into a human whether it by
default or design gives them a fairly
innocuous low-key personality because so
far we've only ever seen that being used
to help time wish to hide out and if
you're hiding out you want to keep
low-key so I I'm heck I'm gonna head
candidate that part of the chameleon
arts is to give them a kind of subdued
meeker personality so that they don't
make waves and don't get noticed too too
much if they cannot all help it but that
was really interesting to see pan out so
getting back to some of the spoilers
from earlier that I had to skip over I
really loved so the starship of Theseus
if you haven't already listened to it
but and you don't care about spoilers so
the thought exercise the Ship of Theseus
is this idea of okay so there's this
ship owned by a guy named Theseus and at
one point a board starts to rot so he
replaces that board
and over enough time he replaces another
board and another board and over a long
enough time eventually every single
board has been replaced and not a single
plank of the original ship is still
there is it still the ship of theseus
and if it's and if it is how when none
of the original physical materials still
present and if it isn't at what point
did it become no longer the original
ship when it was halfway converted all
the way the minute you changed even one
plank of it when does that change and I
love seeing that applied to narrative
being it starts out with the doctor
who's with the companion that you know
he has an established rapport with
Sheena and then a little bit later he
calls her Emma and then it turns out oh
no no that's not my name is something
else and like things are changing and
initially is that a nine o'clock and
initially kushina's not a recurring
companion so when he said the name a
second time or something else like oh I
thought he said Sheena oh but then it
changed again I'm like wait a minute and
then you know we're finding out the ship
it was originally it was a cruise line
oh now it's a refugee ship and and just
seeing the changes and it's some of them
are lead later on it sleeps but like
little changes to the story that they
are inhabiting and to the point that
Sheena gets erased and now gets thrown
on the pile of companions who just never
were and so that's really clever what
ends up happening with all the Dalek who
doesn't remember being a Dalek that is
kind of really kind of intriguing that
could have been very OneNote I really
enjoyed that and with the conscript I
like the final note with especially the
more sort of patriotic of the recruits
the doctor bonds with sticking to that
and she tells him like look you go meet
your destiny I'm gonna meet mine and I
do appreciate it when somebody in a
situation like that is still going to
stand by their principles even knowing
what it's going to cost them saying look
don't tell me I'm an idiot for doing
this I'm making a choice let me make it
and I do appreciate that overall this
was a pretty good box set not
the best and it did have the one
character who I didn't like but overall
pretty dang good I like the flavor of
the time war that it gives you and it
doesn't shove the doctor too much into
it it does have him sort of skirting
around the edge of it which makes sense
given what we saw in night of the doctor
so Eighth Doctor the time war series one
have you heard it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it there's other stuff to do as
well there's the patreon which helps
support this and it's why I actually got
to listen to this at all plus you know
there's the like to subscribe those are
helpful other links besides click on
them they'll take you places but you
also don't have to because at the end of
the day you're the council I'm only
running meetings and until next time
this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]